thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a very Multicultural
episode of careful boys today we got Geo
over there we got Jesus over here
and a bunch of assorted Asians here and
there
assorted minority today we're gonna
figure out and Nick is Latina adjacent
because they're married to a Latinos
hello get woke Jason and your Latino
adjacent because you use pestles in your
cultures pesos
oh really
well yeah that's that's a good thing you
say that because what we're gonna do
today is we are going to find out yeah
going up in L.A yes or just California
General okay let's figure out as many
commonalities between Mexicans and
Asians that we can think of oh I tell
you the main ones we all beat our kids
yeah we'll get a lot of that that's one
yeah number one child abuse number one
child abuse making Chinese food
[Music]
yeah yeah
uh or well I think addicted to porn both
sides there's a lot of the board
addiction going on there listen I think
you say that with like a lot of
differences yeah
yeah the Asian Latino we're taking it
out and Asians are very like the men are
very like do you know like you've seen a
hot girl walk by with a fat ass like are
Asians and Latinos when I worked in the
kitchen they used to yeah
[Laughter]
when we grew up the way all of our girls
had like the [__] most gangster
eyebrows yes that is true Asians and
Mexican girls
did a lot of Mexican guys like Asian
porn
oh oh how does it have access to it I
don't really yeah I mean why do you go
buy it it's all the pixels and stuff too
I mean I I got introduced to Asian porn
like maybe high school so that's the
internet though I'm saying internet
intriguing to you did you enjoy it oh
yeah oh big time yeah yeah big time
because you know it's something that
you're not used to you're like what's
going on over there what kind of [__]
connections I just like I I think I said
this before I just like the Innocence of
it like
it's
[Laughter]
like
don't be no it's all right the noise
all right all right look I love you dude
like that type of [__] to me was like
the uh oh my God the Innocence
the darkness of me just wanted to [__]
the innocence of this like oh I don't
think oh you did again oh yeah please oh
very yes no please I'm sorry
oh you're freaking forgiven this is a
storyline it just got me going I just be
in my room just going like oh [__] dude
you're a bad guy did you guys did you
guys watch Mexican porn back in the day
Latin porn stars but I don't think it
was Mexican porn
Mexicans
yeah it's like Latina porn stars I think
like latinas are the best like when it
comes to the porn game I think potatoes
are the best like [__] moaners
moaners
fun and like oh yeah baby
some other ones are just a little
aggressive like [__]
in the summer just like very quiet like
enjoy it enjoy it stop holding back stop
making this weird go oh my God you got
the breathers
like oh shut up shut up are we running
what are we doing
all right we're making love here I need
to oh yeah yes
[Music]
the eye is the sexiest moan ever done I
oh hahaha
we found gold baby we found gold the eye
is the best moan oh I'm sorry I mean
keep going oh God gross oh stop dude
[Laughter]
and also I feel like in a positive like
a family orientated we're very family
very family-oriented we hang out with
our family where everyone's in your
[__] business and everyone's got a
[__] judgment on something you
[__] choose the wrong career
everyone's on your case they also they
also don't call you by your first name
they call you by your flaws yes like
badass oh yeah yes dummy yes yes hey you
know what else happens like fat like
fatty or shorty or whatever yeah yeah
like I have an uncle I have an uncle
what's your nickname yeah
I'm working that out there with the
therapy but I have an uncle who was born
with like a crooked hip so we call them
Cumbia
and an uncle it had like a patch he had
no idea
[Laughter]
I'm like
where's the treasure at it used to be
like
let's get it
it's [__] up
they call them carnicero like that's
just his name like butcher yeah
and then like my other Uncle he said
Kukui like yeah yeah the devil yeah and
what was yours
um
call me like Calavera like uh because I
was skinny I guess oh you say that's
[__] up like skeletons
because I'm like the darker one of my
family so I was always better oh yeah
they'll do that too they'll call you
like dark or something
I feel like aunts and uncles they have
to roast you every every Gathering like
they just they'll just talk [__] out of
nowhere they get to like they get
together and they'll have like a row
session of their kids yeah they're all
complaining about their kids talking
[__] about the kid it's like no you
think that was bad
I couldn't read it and everybody's like
oh my God laughing and my dad's just
going making me feel worse we went to
the doctor and we take a scan of his
brain and they're like no he's fine are
you sure because he can't read doc I
don't know okay he must be one of those
like and I'm sitting there just like
what the [__] are you talking about like
like not knowing that they went into
that deep with it is that what we went
to the doctors for because I was super
smart yeah I thought it was a [__]
X-Men dude what are you talking about
you know what you know what both sides
do Latin dancing at parties
yeah I see it I see that I see that ah
Latinos love [__] Tokyo Drifters
since the Racine in general
Furious I think Tokyo Drift is like
important that's why that's why Hector
was such a major character for you guys
I think so yeah
like if you start the uh
in Mexico they're always playing it like
and they're like
restaurants and [__]
with the [__] dub you know they dub
it and [__] oh dude Dragon Ball Z yeah
yeah that's that goes across Latins and
I hate that's the thing about these
shows these are great shows Asian shows
and stuff like that but they dub it and
the dubbing is so terrible they can't
perfect the dubbing it's just oh [__]
[Laughter]
who the [__] is talking like that yeah
but you know also the foods I like
Mexicans love Mariscos and you guys love
as well yes Mariscos I [__] with you
guys uh what'd you guys do with fish and
stuff I'm like okay see what you guys
are doing there so you know what though
I I feel like every time I go to like a
hardcore Asian restaurant where like
they bring out the food with the thumb
still in the bowl and [__] like
dude
yeah I've seen this lady just dumb soup
don't be like Mexican families eating
there too yeah yeah like and then when
you go to like some hardcore ass like
Mexican restaurant where like white
people are too afraid to go to you'll
see some like Chinese family just eating
a turtle yes oh right and we both love
love [__] Chinese buffets I don't
know what it is
I don't know what it is buffets in
general yeah but for Chinese Buffets is
what they they really [__] with they
have like seafood at the buffet too yeah
they got oysters and like they're the
mussels they're not today's video is
brought to you by DraftKings college
football fans are you ready for week one
draftking sports book is hooking you up
with a can't miss offer to start the
season strong this week new customers
can bet with just five dollars on
college football and score two hundred
dollars in bonus bets instantly anything
can happen in college football your team
can go from unranked to Dynasty mode in
just a couple of years change comes fast
the only thing that's a lot is the great
offers from DraftKings Sportsbook life
is more fun when you're in on the action
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now and use the code off the Record new
customers can score two hundred dollars
in bonus bets instantly when they bet
just five dollars on college football
only in draftking sports book with cold
off the Record the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler or
visit
www.1800gabler.net in New York call
8778-hopm
y or text h-o-p-e-n-y in Connecticut
help is available for problem gambling
call
888-789-77 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction void in
Ontario
ccdkng.com football for eligibility
terms and responsible gaming resources
bonus bets expire seven days after
issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply but they call it
oysters
yeah dude everything is oysters today
the shrimp yeah [__] they love shrimp
they [__] gobble down shrimp like a
mother they both like oil stains in
their driveway there's that's very true
yeah I never seen Latino house that
doesn't have an old stain you don't take
your pets to the vet you just kind of
let it sort itself out oh yeah yeah we
let [__] mother nature figure itself
out yeah it's true huh a lot of [__]
uh people love Kobe I'll tell you that a
lot of Asians a lot of Mexicans love
Kobe that's true sports do you guys like
soccer do you guys like soccer oh yeah
out here
Mexicans and Asians love [__]
fireworks
we love anything that goes bang dude
that's what it is which is love yeah I
always feel like in the Asian
neighborhood it's like that one Mexican
house
it depends on what kind of Asian Asians
bring it Mexicans use it
Mexicans Asians that's true a Mexican
also [__] yeah that's the big ones
like okay I wouldn't do it but I'm
selling to you so you can do it so they
just like set everything up and they
[__] watch Latinos get in trouble for
it
you know I mean it's perfect for [__]
come on get in trouble is it is it like
uh I don't know this might be
controversial but like is it like a
thing where
they want to stick with their own people
like do you guys have that too like
Asians just only [__] with Asians and
Mexicans yeah for sure for sure right
yeah is that still going on are we
starting to like loosen up it's on my
Asian Americans
yeah like I'm saying like what I'm
saying is like Mexicans only [__] with
me like they say like oh you're only
gonna marry a Mexican like I want a
Mexican in this house yeah yeah you know
I'm sure I don't know if you had that
yeah and then I'm thinking like Asians
are like oh we only because I I loved
this girl
in high school she was Asian it was
great and she liked me too what kind of
Asian was she the nasty guy
parents had a restaurant
yeah baby so she liked me dude she liked
me too but she told me like I like you
but I can't be with you and I said why
it's like because my family will not
allow Forbidden Love I'm like Forbidden
Love was it brother and then I tried to
be like my dad doesn't give a [__] so I
told him yeah right
just letting you know we don't come
back dude
what are you talking about I'm just
letting you know right now okay I don't
want to break like a mulan's heart
okay
dude when he would come over my dad my
brother would be such a dick he'd be
like count the dogs count the dogs
but then I just felt like that was like
maybe that was an hour era but now I'm
starting to see a lot of people just you
know breaking the rules I think I think
more now yeah I think
dude it's a thing going on right now in
Mexico we've always ate thugs really
didn't know it yeah it's a thing hold on
breaking news right [__] now breaking
news whatever
let me tell you something right now
right now there's a big problem in
Mexico like taco stands that they're
cooking dogs yeah because it's cheaper
but they just catch us stray dogs right
yeah it's cheaper and it's three dogs
and it's food they don't know they just
season it to make it taste like actual
like I can't tell the difference yeah
they don't they're like [__] good at
seasoning too it tastes a little funky
but if you add this it brings out the
cow flavor he's got married
it's really Chihuahua
huh
yeah it's so so people are starting to
catch these like taco stands and then
they say like oh they're cooking actual
dog in there so [__] we're not we're
very just the same dude yeah very subtle
we're trying to you're just trying to
make it you know what I mean I could
just trying to make it I think our
parents when they immigrant over here
they're very they think the same as like
hey don't ask questions just blend in
color yeah yeah and we're just like okay
I'm Blended in knowing that I'm a
[__] citizen I'm like oh I just don't
say nothing just mind your business
[__] I got a birth certificate
yeah but similar work ethic too
like okay okay so does your uh like Asia
culture do you guys call in sick
when you're sick I think you if you do
it's kind of like looked down upon right
yeah it's a [__] move yeah yeah yeah
yeah you got to be dying just tough it
out yeah oh my God I called out one my
dad was like why are you here yeah is it
aren't you working I'm like oh none of
them look at I'm sick dude I have the
flu
go work right now when you're working
you're gonna sweat the flu out
and I'm like oh she goes just show up
and have them kick you out but you still
show up but when they kicked you out I
was like it's not your fault so you feel
more like okay if you want me to leave
Johnson I'll leave you know I want to
work no get the hell out of here you'll
get a sick okay you want me to leave
okay I will come home and be like let's
go do something I'm like sure you rest I
mean you're sick let's go to the river
because he looked at us a day off he's
like let me give me a day off okay let's
go do something
oh dude there's a bunch of rivers in
Arizona dude oh okay I was thinking it
was out here I was like oh in Arizona
there's a bunch of rivers San Dimas
River yeah am I gonna be at the river
[__] Mexicans are the type that will
like if you don't have bathing suit your
underwear is your bathing suit we make
it works right there but yeah
it's very Chinese that's a tiny [__]
wow you guys don't wrap your remote
control and surrender or do you your
whole [__] house is wrapped yeah dude
the remote we have that in common oh
yeah yeah my dad still had till this day
my dad still hasn't removed the the
little Saran Wrap that's attached to the
TV like you know you peel it out yeah
yeah
foreigners and I'm like that that is
ripping up
you're gonna scratch it
[__] bubbling out you're making it
work you're getting bubble stains on it
but let me check it out he wants to make
it last longer yes if you remove the gun
I'll kill you
they've got that thing so yeah they want
to keep everything the way it is so Ram
wrap everything yeah oh you know what
else they have in common is illegal
labor
oh that's a good one paint under the
table too hang on a table Yeah cash baby
specifically child labor as well I was
working in construction when I was 14
years old dude everyone was getting paid
500 a week you got paid
thank you my uncle would [__] opinion
but oh okay okay yeah it is good it
sounds great but guess what dude that's
what the white man was giving me he's
like I've never seen a kid work this
hard it must be here you go Amigo I can
500 you earned it because he was like
proud to see a young kid trying to yeah
feed his family he thought I had a
family or some [__] he [__] felt bad
for me he thought
thank you
I work very hard my family's gonna
really appreciate it so he was just like
and then my uncle he's like hey guys
the gas is 200.
uh another 100 because I got you the job
okay so all my thing was going up to
them and I walked away with a hundred
dollars and my dad would tell me 500 is
too much for one kid
dad let him down
you have to pay 150 for food minimum and
I have to pay for any bills at 14
learning how to build he's like I'm
teaching you how to pay bills and be
responsible that kind of money
[Music]
is true yeah it's all yeah but I was
working at 14.
what kind it was uh it started off no it
started up well framing I was a framer
okay it started off with like take out
the trash cute [__] like yeah everything
up put it in there and then I would like
work really fast so I can trust I
thought that was like my dad was always
like finish it fast fast fast and then
they told me like take your time because
we don't have nothing for you to do so
I'm like [__] so then now they threw my
ass in the roof I should have taken my
time because now I'm in the roof with a
[__] rope because they don't have no
like you know say harness harnesses was
it a rope and I just [__] and they'll
just put the little wood and I have to
hang it in there and then they're
[__] da da [__] fingers right here
in the hammer bam and I'm like
and then just kept going I just had to
hang on to the wood while they're
hammering it oh [__] and I'm in the sun
I'm just [__] drenched like God damn
like a Visa dude
you see those looking the people that
are gonna own by the house they'll show
up with their kids they're like my age
oh and I'll be watching them and they're
just looking they're over there playing
tag animals they're like I want to be
American just walk around yeah right
what am I doing here I should be the
supervisor what the [__] is going on
wait I got to see a bunch of [__] like
um
just the way that Mexicans work and [__]
and like that was [__] tough like
hardcore labor like hardcore [__] you
know you know but anyway and also they
gave me like the nail gun which is like
why would you give a 14 year old kid the
nail gun I almost killed myself with the
nail gun I think I looked at it no no
but I almost didn't kill myself one time
though one time it was a true story true
[__] story yeah cause like what
happened was the nail gun you have to
press it and then that nail comes out
yeah
right and it got stuck no so what
happened was when you press it
even if you press it it just
automatically comes out
that's easier it's like a like like a
little safety like you know you lock it
in you just press it so that's what they
were doing and then I was holding the
wood and then the guy next that was
doing it went like this in my [__]
forehead and then what and I just felt
air because he ran out of oh my God
I think about that [__] all the time all
the time I'm always driving and I'm
and I'm at One Nail and that's like
Russian Roulette [__] right there what
if there was one now left in that [__]
like well I would be telling like
they'll be telling my dad hey come get
your son he died like the you know like
the news would have came it was a kid
got killed you know what I mean it's all
it would have been a disaster
just because he [__] ran out of nails
and he was like okay and then
accidentally he was gonna ask for more
nails and he accidentally hit my
forehead
um
and then it's my fault it's always your
fault
are you there
why are you so close to me like an idiot
move gotta removed
that is the final true commonality is
their fault make them Blaze oh my God
it's never their fault bro did I put my
face what happened
[Laughter]